so i'm one down
i haven't played so well so far
gotta gotta try and turn it up at some
point
and he goes for i guess the same line
i wouldn't say i'm that worried
i feel like the position i've got was
was quite okay
what if i go a6 it goes bishop c4 and i
can
play with first setup with e6 and b5
seems reasonable no
that's the point
what about 9585 queen a52 knight before
king d1 i can take it in d5
king e2
then there's queen c5
oh there's c3 knight e5 b4 but then i
have queen c7
there is probably some reputation since
he's playing so fast but i can't see it
way far is probably the reputation there
queen c5 knight b392
king d1
okay i'll play e7x
takes f6 he's got to play c4 at some
point
no just c3
okay i guess we'll we'll just develop
didn't like the
queen on f6 so i'm gonna put that
somewhere else
but i guess here he will go for a
moderate c bind
c4 at some point and be a time bit
better
okay
maybe i shouldn't go b i'll go b6
you'll go yeah queen e2 then bishop b3
or bishop f4 still is a little bit
better
it seems very innocuous but still
he's
this is slightly better here
i wanna i go h6 in order to go bishop f6
next
possibly i didn't want to allow
okay this is alive for him
yeah i guess he gets bishop g3 to
protect this
pawns but his weakness came
fairly seriously and though although i
have these
somewhat ugly double pawns i think
that is uh that is a serious factor okay
i'll go bishop c6 if it takes an
a6 i take on d1 and then a4 so i'm not
losing a pawn
and i'm possibly preparing b5 at some
point
i think he will go k to f3 at some point
but again his king is seriously weakened
now i'm using the tactical chance to go
b5
just wanna open some things up should i
run bishop b5
maybe i should have
but anyway i just spent weights spend
way too much time on these subtleties
okay which bay 8 was also possibly
possible tactically speaking but i i
didn't
didn't actually like it hpa it feels
correct attacking c3
queen b2 it's moving a lot of pieces
away from the
from the king side okay
we'll go rook
dnc8 i guess
attack something as long as i can rook
c1
okay now i have a double attack
d3 and h4
and i will lose e5 but that is a double
pawn that i'm losing and
his king will be fairly deprived of
cover
afterwards so i think this is a great
trade for me
just go bish best six i think
get rid of those bishops and then
prey on his weaknesses
bishop e2 is not a bad choice for him
here
then queen f6 queen b6 he has bishop d4
you can also go bishop d4 immediately
but i think i'll take then
and possibly go h5 afterwards
looks fairly promising yeah he went for
he went for rich beats too which is a
little annoying
okay we'll go queen e7 bishop d6 queen
a7
bishop c5 queen c7 i feel like i've
achieved
i've achieved something because my queen
is kind of invading
just kind of
i can also sack the exchange but i don't
want to do that
let's just keep the tension for the
moment
okay let's go h5 open up this king
so obviously keep the tension but open
his king when i have the
when i have the opportunity
okay we'll take h5
give a check
it's looking very promising for me now
g5 is an option e5 looks
fairly promising actually f4 there's
queen e4
he's gonna go queen g5 i think
hard to not imagine another move
yeah he did that so
i've at least won a pawn
i guess he does have some drawing
chances
okay do a check
can't be too wrong
okay let's go it should be three i guess
and give another check
okay he's threatening bishop sex
she's annoying me a bit
okay i gotta i got a plan
don't think too much
that's what he wanted it's a bit
surprising
just getting a bit nervy that's for sure
attack something while i can
this one i didn't see but i have king of
seven
later on i should have done it
immediately immediately of course
okay f7 still should be
six winning another pawn
should be
should be enough to win the game unless
i mess up
in a major way
okay we've got a bishop name five
oh that didn't win immediately as i
hoped
it should win gradually on the rook
ending
okay we just run
rg5 kd4 take e4
done this is quite similar to the first
game of the match
and my king is just
too well placed
chances for him okay
a couple of nervy games there wow